欢迎收看独大的线上课程
那今天想跟你分享的是如何利用谈起来通道
我们来去抓住这个行情的趋势
那如果对于想要掌握趋势有兴趣的朋友
你一定要看今天的影片哦
大家好,我叫独大,我是一个专职的投资人
我平常都在交易股票、期货跟选人权
所以我会以专职交易的角度来跟你分享投资这件事情
所以你也是同好的话,请你订阅我的频道
那我频道里面有各式各样的教学
股票、期货、选人权的技术分析都有哦
那我在街头看出的三本书
赢债修正的股市上盘绝技
还有赢债加码还有选人权获利秘技
对于交易有兴趣的朋友
你可以从这三本书开始看起
书的连结在影片的下方有
那如果最后你想要今天简报的话
请先加入我们LINE ATLINE
上是小老鼠OPTI1
书的关键字23101
可以得到今天简报
那我们LINE ATLINE
平常也有提供一些免费的台股的资讯
跟筹码资讯在这边
你可以看到更多的好的东西
我们分享一下
我们在10月底
会有Winsmart的线上讲座
欢迎你对Winsmart有兴趣的朋友可以参加
如果你看影片已经错过时间的话
没关系
我们一样每个月都会有一场最新的场次
今天想跟大家分享的Don't Train Channel
它是一个专职的期货交易员
他是期货出身
就跟大家一样
它的交易概念是这样子
我们去做交易就是要抓住行情的趋势
那我怎么知道行情的趋势发生呢
这很简单
就是这个行情它去做一个区间的突破
例如说股价它突破最近半年的新高
它就是一个新的趋势的发生
或者是价格突破最近三个月的新高
它就是一个趋势的产生
所以这个概念就是说
这个商品它突破一个区间的高点
我们去做多
或者是这个商品突破一个区间的低点
我们就要去放空
这个是区间突破顺势交易的概念
非常有名的海归交易法则
他们就是利用唐奇洋通道
然后来去做一个改良
它的改良方式是这样子
它一样是用区间K棒的高低点来去做个突破
例如说他们在书里面有分享说
他们怎么在市场上面赚了非常非常多的钱
就是年化报酬率80%你知道吗
年化报酬率80%
这非常非常高
每年都几乎是倍数成长
资金一直翻倍
那它是用怎么样的方式来去做
他们是用区间突破
例如说它这个价格突破20天的高点的话
它是一个买进的条件
等到价格跌破10天的低点的话
他来去做个出场
这是一个长期让通道的应用
趋劲突破来去做进场
如果是长期让的话
就突破55天的高点来去做个进场
如果跌破20天的低点的话
就来去做个出场
这是个海贝交易
里面一个非常有效的交易方式
这个也是被广泛的来去当做
一个城市交易的逻辑
这个交易的方法
海贝他们也真的用城市交易
来去做个回测发现可以赚钱
他们在真实交易的时候也是用这个方法来去做交易
他公开在书上面
这个是我们现在城市交易的一个非常好的一个
初始一个模型
就是用区间突破的方式来去做个交易
好 那我们来看一下
假设我们来去回测这个台子旗的这个商品走势图
我们用30分k的话
那回测的时间是从2000年到2023年
经过2023年的时间的k棒
那如果在这个期间
你这个K棒的突破30根K棒的高点的话
你来说进场买进
然后跌破10根K棒低点的时候
你来去做个卖出
那么你得到的绩效会长这个样子
就是他也是一个慢慢向上的一个走势图
长期来看的话你的获利是可以成长的
那如果你是用5分K来去做个回撤的话
那我们可以说5分K如果假设这个商品
他突破110根K棒的高点来去做进场的话
然后等到这个价格跌破50根K棒低点
来去做个出场的话
那么你回撤你所得到的这个绩效的走势图在下方
就是你的获利不断的创新高
那这个就是一个趋势交易的一个交易的策略
它就是利用谈其样通道
然后来去做一个修正
把它变成一个交易的一个方式
所以我今天想跟大家分享
如何利用一个突破的策略
有机会在市场上面赚到钱
首先我们来看一下谈其样通道
它的公式它是怎么算的
它很简单
它有三条线
一个是上通道
一个是下通道
一个是中通道
上通道的话怎么画出来呢
就是用n跟k棒的高点把它给画出来
例如说这个n跟k是20跟k棒的高点
或是50跟k棒的高点
把它给画出来
画成一个连线
那下通道的话
就是最近n跟k棒的最低点
把它给画出来
把它画成一个连线
那中通道就是上通道加上下通道
加起来除以2
这是平均值的概念叫做中通道
所以唐奇洋通道的话
它原始的发明的话
它是有三条件
上通道下通道以及中通道
那谈其他通道呢
它就是利用一个区间的突破
来去抓一个航行可能的一个进场点
例如说像这个地方
航行往下突破区间呢
对不对
所以航行往下跌
那在这个地方呢
航行往上突破区间的
所以航行往上走一段
在这里
航行往下跌破新的区间的话
所以航行往下跌一段
所以它就是利用一个区间突破
来当做一个可能的一个
航行的发动的进场点
它是属于一个顺势交易的一个策略
我们在讲顺势交易策略的时候
我们先有概念
所有的趋势策略
它通通在趋势盘的时候可以赚钱
例如说
现在行情它是在个多头的话
你用所有的趋势策略
应该都要赚到钱
这个想要趋势
例如说你在行情突破区间的时候
你还去做进场
你进场以后后面行情再走一段
所以你就可以赚到钱
例如说苹果这张股票
它的价格走势
它长期它是个大多头的走势
你用这种股票
你去用唐奇亚趋势通道来去做一个交易的话
它绩效一定是漂亮的
所以空头走势也是一样
空头走势你用趋势交易策略的话
你是有机会赚到钱的
怎么说呢
因为当这个行情往下跌破的时候
后面行情还是跌大段
所以你是跌破的时候
你来去放空
你是有机会赚到钱
因为它是走一个趋势
趋势策略在什么地方不会赚钱的
趋势策略在不连续的时候
它就应该是不会赚钱
OK
比如说
趋劲突破的时候你来去做多然后做多以后航行掉下來停損掉然後行情往下跌破的时候你还去做放空放空以后行情又手上去你又停损掉然后行情突破区间高点的时候
你又做多
做多以后行情掉下来
像这种区间盘
像这种双八盘
在这个趋势策略去做突破交易的话
应该是赚不到钱的
所以我们去做交易的时候
我们先要有一个概念是什么概念
就是你是用什么策略来去做交易
你在什么样的行情会赚到钱
你要先有这个认知
那我今天想跟大家分享的是
近尖版的檀奇安通道
因为传统的檀奇安通道
它只有三条线
它有上轨、中轨跟下轨
它有这三条线
那我怎么改良呢
我们保留了上通道跟下通道
跟中通道这三条线
我们多加了什么东西呢
我们多加了黄金分割率在里面
我们有一部影片叫做黄金分割率
它是来计算行情的回档
什么时候会遇到支撑
什么时候遇到压力
这是叫黄金分割率
0.382 0.618 0.5
我把这个黄金分割率的概念
我们加到这个弹前要通道里面
比如说我这边要放上三条线
下面的这个红色这条线
就是叫做低通道
它是个0.382
那上面这个绿色这条线叫做高通道
它是0.618
它这个计算的方式是这样子的
就是用这个上下通道
这个当做百分之百
那如果从最底下反弹
0.382的话
就是到这个低通道的位置
反弹0.5的时候到中通道的位置
反弹0.618的时候到这个高通道的位置
所以我们把这个唐其量通道
我们加上黄金分割率把它加上去
因为大自然的法治
可能在黄金分割率的时候
它会自然的遇到支撑跟压力
所以我把黄金分割率
加上这个唐其量通道把它加上去
我们参数是这样子
我们这边有三个参数
打开我们这个WinSmart的画面给你看一下
好那这个是最新的行情
上面有一个唐其量通道
我们看一下这个中间
我把这个打开来看一下
这个中间参数可以改
你可以自己打0.382
你可以打0.618
你可以打0.225
所以你要打什么样参数
你可以自己来去做个修改
这个参数都是可以自己来去做个调整的
好
那如果我用0.382的话
我们就可以看到说
这个行情从高点掉下来反弹幅度
如果你0.382都不到的话
这个叫做是反弹
你知道我意思吗
连0.382
这个百分比都不过的话
这个叫做是反弹
所以我可以看一下这个行情
假设行情从上面掉下来
我看它反弹幅度到底是多大
这是我把这个弹其样通道
加上红金分割率在上面
来去衡量这个行情的反弹幅度的一个强弱
接下来我看一下这个弹其样通道的一个交易的用法
就是上面用它来去做个突破
像例如说这个行情往下来去做个跌破的话
它可能是一个行情的转弱点
转空点
OK
那这个突破以后
我们看到这个弹其样通道
它呈现一个样态
什么样的样态
就是往下跌破以后
这个行情它不断创新低
所以下通道它也不断的来去做破滴
OK 因为为什么
因为去这K棒的低点
就不断创新低
对对
所以唐前要通道
它就不断的往下化
这个下轨就不断的往下化
然后上通道
这是上轨的位置
它经过一段时间
它才会跟着往下
而上通道它维持在高档一段时间
一段时间过后
它才开始往下
为什么你知道吗
因为唐奇洋通道它是区间k棒的高低点
对不对
例如说我看60根k棒
而这个唐奇洋通道
它要经过60根k棒以后
它才会下修
它才会跟着往下走
要不然最近60根k棒的高点
全部都在同个位置
对不对
直到怎么样
直到60根k棒过去以后
它才会开始往下来去做一个跟进
OK吗
所以我们去看这个唐奇洋通道的走势
区间突破的那一方
它这个通道它会下降的比较快
而另外一方他就会反应会比较慢
如果是弹枪通道参数是60的话
他经过60跟k棒以后才会往下跌
弹枪通道是200的话
他大概经过200跟k棒他才会往下跌
知道为什么
然后接下来我们在上面放上一个
这个黄金分割率
如果我们看这个价格走势
连这个最下面的0.382都没有反弹过的话
这个叫做一个弱势的反弹
这个是非常强劲的空头
我们可以把这个黄金分割率
来当做行情强弱的一个温度计
好 接下來看一下
彈起來通道的突破
如果是往上突破的話 航行轉強
如果我在這裡做買進的話
航行也真的走一段滿對不對
就是做突破的
好 我們來看一下
突破以後上通道他會不斷的往上走
只要這個價格不斷創新高的話
它是符合什麼 符合多頭理論
多頭理論 道次理論是什麼叫多頭
就是一頭比一頭高
不斷創新高 這個才是多頭對不對
然後一底比一底高
你可以看到這個一底比一底
它剛好就是拉回打到什麼
拉回打到我们这个
航行通道的黄金分割率上面
拉回打到0.5的位置有增
这个行情涨上去拉回
打到0.382的位置有增就上去
这个叫拉回0.382在这个位置
所以我们可以用这个黄金分割率下上
航行通道来去判断行情的强弱
跟来去判断行情可能拉回的支撑的位置
而这个下通道它的反应速度会比较慢
它会先横的走一阵子
然后后面行情才会跟上
就是堂琴要通道的一个样子
如果这个行情在一个非常狭窄的区间
那代表什么样
代表说例如说60根K棒200根K棒
它就是在一个非常狭窄的区间
非常狭窄的区间的话
那非常棒
代表说行情它正在压缩
压缩以后行情一定会突破
如果是行情突破的话
这个通道就会打开来
它就会打开
然后如果行情是盘整的话
这个通道它就会来去做个收敛
接下来我们介绍长期通道的股票交易策略
第一个动作你当然是先选股
对不对
但是最好是选择一路往上涨的股票
因为你用这个趋势策略
只有在趋势盘会赚钱
你选一个不会动的
你怎么用趋势策略呢
所以第一个你要选标地
那怎么选标地呢
你可以选择强势股
或者是选择就是
股息不断成长的
股价也不断上涨的一个股息成长股票
就是概念是往上走的股票比较适合
第二个在趋势持续的情况之下
你用突破交易策略他是可以成功的然后第三个怎么做你可以用海归交易法则海归交易法则他不是说突破20日的高点进场然后跌破10日的低点来去做出场
我们用这个
谭奇洋通道策略
或者是海归交易法则
我们示范给你看一下
好各位同学我们先看一下这档股票叫做
2376的技嘉
这个技嘉前面涨一大段
然后现在有点这个
好像有点做头了
我看一下用谭奇洋策略的话
你可以在哪边进场
可以在哪边出场
到这边我们预设参数我们是用20天
因为刚刚我们的逻辑是突破20日的高点来去做进场
对不对
所以我用这个图形先解释给你听
他是怎么运作
例如说这个行情他只要往上涨
他创新高
你可以说突破一个月的高点
创新高
或者是突破一年的高点
你知道我意思吗
就是突破一个区间的高点
而最近20天的高点我帮你画出来了
高点在这个位置
我们在突破20天的高点的时候
我们来去做进场
示范给你看一下
好,在这个地方
突破20天的高点
我们来去做进场
突破一个趋近Camp-on高点
好,进场
假设你的条件是要跌破20日的低点
来去做出场的话
我们这边设定一下条件
假设我的出场条件是20日的低点
来去做出场的话
这边是打20
那它的结果会长这个样子
把这个速度调快点
好,那接下来我们这个出场条件
我们再盯住这个20日的Camp-on低点
我们来看一下
上面是上轨20天K棒的高点
下面是下轨20天K棒的低点
那我们刚刚所设定的出场条件
我们就是用20天K棒的低点
加1%来当做出场条件
对不对
你这样去设好的话就是这样子
我会跟着这个20天的低点来当做出场条件
ok然后行情我就一直爆
我就一直爆
行情在震荡的时候
我这个
出在这个位置
就是行情跌破20天K棒的低点的时候
我来去做天机出场
也差不多是跌破这个头部的位置
来去做出场
或是跌破这个高档的盘子去出场
以做这个长线角度来看的话
我觉得还可以
它就是一个长线的交易策略
在这个时候
这个电脑前面的你可能会想
想什么东西
就是我用下面这条线
好像出场好像出的有点慢
我可不可以出的快一点
可不可以出的快点
可以
你就不要看20天K放低点
你改成看10根K放低点
一定会出更快
所以海归交易就是把弹其量通道来去做个改良
他不是用20天K棒低点来去做出场
他用10根K棒低点
那我们把这个改良版的弹其量通道打开给你看一下
我们参数上面可以定义
上面是差不多20根K棒的高点
那底下我们可以把参数改成不一样
例如说改成10根K棒的低点
我们重划一下
重划一下的话它就比较快
我们看到
下面这条线是我们刚刚的移动体力的轨迹
如果你把出场条件改成
看10根K棒的话
你的出场条件就会大幅的往上来
就是一个拉伸
我demo给你看一下
好行情趋近突破
突破20日的高点
我们来去做进场
所以上面是20根k棒的高点
下面是10根k棒的低点
那我们就来去做一个移动停地
然后跟店长讲说
跟着这个10根k棒的低点
再往下加一点点百分比
来当做出场条件
那我现在最新的设定条件
是看10根k棒的低点
对不对
价格跌破的话
我就来去做个停地出场
那后面行情如果创新高的话
上面是创新高
那底下是出场条件
所以我先把出场条件
我把它简化了
把它变成比较近的
本来是看20天变成看10天
所以我会出的比较快
所以获利回准比较不会这么样的大
OK吗
就是我把这个条件改小了
那你也可以把这个10天低点改成5天低点
对不对
你会出更快
这样知道为止吗
如果你是改成3根K帮低点的话
价格只要跌破3根K帮低点的话
1 2 3
OK 这根就出场
你知道为什么
跌破前面三根K棒的低点
这个叫三根K棒的低点
所以你可以自己决定说
在几根K棒低点的时候
你来去做个停利出场条件
然后把这个行情把它拉长来看一下
我们从底下突破区间K棒高点进场
然后用区间K棒低点出场的概念
最后一张股票从底下抱上来也赚了15万8
对不对
你用这个模式可以做非常多的股票
你知道我意思吗
我们去做交易
可以套用交易的获利方程式
也就是我只用一套方法做交易
而且上面找适合这套方法交易的商品来去做
比如说我们看一下股票
3596的这个智义
这个智义它现在突破
区间K棒的高点
对不对
突破一个月的K棒高点
所以我们来去做进场
进场以后
接下来我们去用刚刚的移动停地
我们根据这个10根K棒的低点
我这边是再加2%
来当做一个移动停地的条件
下个没有跌破的话
我的多单的部位就去报
所以我进场以后
我就怎么样是抱住我的一个股票
对对
所以我去做交易
就是你要同样一个方法
你可以重复来去做交易
就是选择适合这个方法的商品来去做交易
那我再给你一个小小的技巧
就是怎么样选
怎么样选股
怎么选
你可以看这个投信
他只要连续买钞
你看一下这底下是投信的这个筹码
投信他只要连续买钞
这个股票他就容易一路涨
这个投信手码股
所以可以选择被投信锁住的标第五投信不当买超
这个股价就会一路上涨
所以我们就可以套用这个海归交易法则
可以套用这个谈其样通道的一个突破策略
这个价格它只要没有跌破
例如说10个KRM低点
我就可以股票来去做续报
那我去做这个字役的话
一档股票从底下报上来
我一张也赚了62,000
我们接下来讲谈其样通道的期货交易策略
首先我们要为这个商品
找到一个适合的通道的参数
比如说60 100 200
你要先找到SERTA的参数
然后第二个进场方式
我们可以用区间突破进场
我们也可以用黄金分割率来去做进场
稍后来去做一个示范
然后最后一个
我们可以用区间KBUN高低点
来当做我们一个出场的条件
我示范给你看
好的 现在打开我们的WinSmart的
期货的看板画面
这跟KBUN它往下来去做一个跌破
好 那我们打开我们这个WinSmart
我们准备来去做一个交易
我们上面放上什么
放上这个弹其量的一个通道
然后中间有三条线
就是看这个黄金分割率这个行情往下跌破跌破他现在正在反弹假设我试着经常来做放空放空以后停损离开设高点现在设定一个40点
当做一个停损条件
看错赔钱的话就赔8000块
看这个行情走
看这个行情他正在往下
行情他正在往下往下来做个突破
看到我往下来做个突破
然后行情反弹
行情反弹再跌破再往下跌
我们可以看到这个行情
他来是做个反弹
那反弹这个地方用弯头的位置
他刚好弹到0.618的位置
这个上面这条线叫做0.618
所以我们可以利用这三条线
房间分割率来看到这个行情反弹的强弱
给这个行情他在这个地方震荡
然后我们进场以后就不用管他了
因为我们条件已经设定好了
我们用什么条件来去当做一个出场条件
我这边条件我是看20根的K棒
然后再加30点
来当做我的一个出场条件
我这边是跌破60根的k棒
我来去做一个进场
来去找进场点
然后我用20根的k棒来当做一个出场条件
我们可以看到你进场的方式有两种
有哪两种
第一种的方式就是突破的时候进场
例如说往下跌破进场
这个往下跌破进场
往下跌破进场
第二个方式是反弹空
这三条线
这个黄金分割率的0.382
0.5跟0.618
就是让你反弹空的一个参考值
反弹到00382涨动放空
或者是行情反弹到00618往下掉的时候放空
就是这三条线是给你来当做参考的用的
OK好
那我们就是用两种方式
你可以选择
我放上这个指标
看得比较细一点
我们做台子期看得比较细一点
我要放上这个弹气量通道
再加上这个黄金分割率
我们看得细一点
而这个蓝色的线就是你的出场条件
我们试看最近20根的K棒
然后再加30点来当做提供条件
也就是说行情区间突破的话
我就来去做停泌出场
那行情它如果反弹不够高的话
我就继续抱住我的空档部位
我们刚刚进场以后我们设停水
然后接下来其实你不用看盘
你知道为什么吗
你可以利用这个你设定好的条件
让这个程式它自动化的方式
来帮助你来去做执行
那这个行情什么时候出场
它达到你的蓝色的这个价格停泌线
就是看20个跟K棒的高点
来当做你的出场条件
行情达到的话就出场
OK我们在这个地方出场
我们这一波下来
我们赚了2万块钱
我们用8000块的风险
来去换个2万块的获利
也不错
赚盘比超过两倍以上
大概是2.5倍
那这样子我们就是个期货的
一个小段落的交易的示范
大概是报了一天
那我们再找一段做给你看一下
我们现在来去做交易
来看一下这个弹奇亚通道
在这个地方
它是突破60根的K棒
所以你可以在突破的时候来去做多
或者是我们刚刚讲过
你可以等它拉回的时候做多
拉回到哪边
拉回到这个黄金分割率
0.382 0.5 0.618的时候来去找进场点
都可以我们观察一下
行情上去
它有点回档的弯头的现象
所以我们等到弯头结束以后
我们再来去做进场
拉回买进的想法
点蛮深的
这个地方拉回买进
行情从上面到这个位置
回档是0.618的位置
它又开始涨向上
所以我试着来去做多
在这个地方买进
是比在突破的时候买进
你的成本更好
对不对
如果行情真的上去的话
你可以赚更多
这个是期货短线必须要计较的事情
因为期货短线就是
因为做短线的时候
你必须要计较那个点数
所以你拉回买进
你赚的一定会比突破买进的时候还要多
所以你看行情
行情没有很强的话
可以等拉回买
行情真的很强的话
我们才去做突破
知道我意思吗
那你进场以后
这个蓝色的线就是你的出场条件
就是我们刚刚设定
我们设定什么东西
我们设定就是看20根的K棒
的低点再加个30点来当做我的停利的条件
ok
这看去电K棒的高低点的概念
这个时候你就不用管它了
如果你想再进场的话
你可以用这个黄金分割率
来去找你可能要的进场点
而这个地方行情来去做个去电突破
去电突破以后
这边走个趋势坛
它非常强
因为这边行情已经大涨197点
这个地方就不太会拉回
就是交易你要有概念
就是盘整的时候会拉回
然后行情走趋势的时候
拉尔幅度是不大的
这个地方已经涨了200多点
所以如果你在今天才进场的话
我建议怎么样
我建议一开盘以后
就找机会来去找进场点
因为它总是走得非常的强
来去这个强突破
这个蓝色的天气线
是我的出场条件
你只要把条件设定好
可以让这个电脑
智慧化的方式来帮助
来去做交易
你不用盯盘
你不用说我要一直看盘
这个行情从早上的9点
到晚上的9点
你也看一整天
看12个小时
不可能
对对
太辛苦了
不会有人这样干的
因为真的没那个体力
没那个时间
你总是要吃饭
总是要睡觉
总是要开车上班
对不对
总是要打捷律
所以你不可能整天在看盘
这个看盘工作交给谁
交给电脑
交给WinSmart
所以我们WinSmart提供给你什么
提供给你聪明的AI的条件设定
你把条件设定好了
就是进出有据
我们最多赔8000块
我们这样账上获利
已经到5万多了
出场也是可以赚了4万多
我们最后出场赚了4万2000块
我们用8000块的风险来赚个42000的获利
赚赔比拉到1比5
这段多也是不错的一个交易
所以你可以用一个聪明的方式
在市场上面做单
我们提供好用的技术指标
我们更提供了好用的人工智慧的下单软体
可以让你非常聪明的方式
在市场上面能够交易
如果对我们这个软体有兴趣
对我们这个指标有兴趣
对我们这个教学有兴趣的话
欢迎来参加我们的WinSmart的线上座谈会
WinSmart的线上座谈会
在我们这个10月底会有一场
分别在礼拜六礼拜天礼拜一
报名网址在影片的下方
如果我们看影片已经错过时间的话
没有关系
你可以报名当月份最新的场次
每个月都会有一场
那如果最后你想要今天简报的话
请先加入我们LINE ATLINE
是小老鼠OPTRE
输入关键字23101
可以得到今天的简报
那我们LINE ATLINE
平常也有提供一些免费的台股的资讯
跟筹码资讯在这边
你可以看到更多的好的东西
好 那我们今天的分享就到这边
感谢你的收看
我们下次见